so something very interesting is clearly
going on when we look at this pencil
dipped in this cup of water
we would expect if maybe there was no
water in this glass that we would just
see the pencil continue straight down in
a line that looks something like that
but that's clearly not what we are
seeing it looks like once we fill it
with water at least to our eye it looks
like the pencil gets bent or broken or
bent in some way
and this notion you might have heard
people call it refraction but it's
interesting to think about exactly why
this is happening and i'll give you a
hint this is all about the bending of
light and it's not just light that can
get bent as it goes from one medium into
another it can be any kind of wave
so let's think about what's going on
over here so first let's think about the
part of the pencil that is above the
water so this part right over here the
light is actually reflecting off of this
pencil and then it's bouncing straight
into our eye so just imagine a path from
this dot straight into your eye once
again from here it's going straight into
your eye when we go over here it still
doesn't look too distorted so you have
light that's going straight to your eye
it's going through the side of the glass
and then getting to your eye
but then once we get into the water
something's interesting you would expect
the point that what would have been here
would then go straight to your eye just
like everything up here but it turns out
that that light once it transitions from
going from the water to the glass and
then the air it bends so at the
interface between the media between
those different materials that the light
is traveling through instead of going
towards your eye it gets bent in this
case to our left and so that's why when
we look straight on here we don't see
anything in this region right over here
but the light that was going from the
pencil towards this part of the glass
which typically you would not see that
would have typically just gone straight
in that direction and not hit your eye
well now that is getting refracted it's
getting bent to the left so that now
that light hits your eye so that's why
you see what looks like a broken pencil
it's all about the light getting bent as
it exits the water and goes into the
glass
and then the air